hey everyone oh lordy there's lots of
babies in there hey one I'm a be sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen if you've been
following along on my Instagram feed you
probably noticed that I'm well into
exploring solids using baby led weaning
for little baby easy so today I
partnered with baby gourmet who
sponsored this video to share my easy
template for building balanced meals for
baby I'm a big fan a baby core made
because their products have no fillers
no added salt or sugars and no
artificial preservatives of any kind and
they're perfect for little cell feeders
like baby eat so generally I like to
think about the day as a whole and
ensure that baby's nails are balanced
nutritionally overall so when I'm
building my meals I like to try to
include four or five different foods at
breakfast lunch and dinner typically
that means including vegetables and
fruit whole grains or starchy foods
protein and iron rich foods if your baby
is really predictable in what they eat
then having one source of iron is
probably just fine however sometimes my
son likes to get into a bit of a
throwing mood and he'll chuck one source
of iron straight to my dog
so since iron is really my priority I
typically like to have a backup so I
know this sounds a lot more complicated
than it actually is so today I'm going
to show you how to build a full day of
really balanced meals for baby so first
up let's talk about breakfast so I love
to cut up avocado into strips that are
really easy for baby to grab and I could
super ripe avocado I simply just roll it
into a little bit of infant cereal
because that adds some extra iron and
adds grip I'm also serving some full fat
plain Greek yogurt with a little swirl
of some fruit and veggie puree in there
for some not
and some additional fruits and
vegetables I love toast so I'm doing
some whole grain toast spread with a
very thin layer of natural peanut butter
and I've cut it into strips
finally eggs are a morning staple so
I've just made a really simple omelet
that I've cut into strips for easy
grabbing now let's look at our tech list
[Music]
okay so let's move on to lunch so for
lunch I've got one of my son's favorites
this is steamed broccoli with a bit of
the stock still attached so it's easier
for him to pick it up themself eat I've
done the same thing with my baked sweet
potato and added a little bit of
cinnamon on there for some extra flavor
instead of salt next I'm serving a
handful of baby gourmet organic carrot
sticks finger foods me with lentil and
chickpeas baby eat loves these both as
part of his meals and as an on the go
snack and I love them too because
they're packed with plant-based protein
iron and tummy friendly probiotics with
no added sugar or salt plus are the
perfect finger shapes so they're great
for self feeders like baby finally I've
got some baked salmon seasoned with a
little bit of dried thyme and olive oil
that I made sure was free of bones
before I served as a baby
alright let's run through that checklist
finally it let's round things off for
dinner so tonight I'm serving some green
beans that I've trimmed and steamed
until they're really tender I usually
have to serve this with a little bit of
lemon juice and avoid any salt for baby
so today my family is having an Italian
theme supper so I decided to make some
mini meatballs with some eggs iron
fortified infant cereal some medium
ground beef dried oregano and no added
salt to go with it I'm serving some a
fortified whole grain [ __ ] Lea pasta
with a little homemade tomato sauce on
top and to finish off the night I'm
serving one of baby's all-time favorites
fresh watermelon so I usually like to
cut this into finger-like strips but you
can also serve it with the rind on if
your babies having difficulty with your
grip back to her checklist
well moms and dads I hope this video
gave you a little insight into how I
build balanced meals for baby eat using
baby wipes feeding techniques a big
thank you again to Baby gourmet for
sponsoring this video if you loved it be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with some of your baby's
favorite finger foods subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye